[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute gibt es einen ganz ganz schnell
network skis cache und ich habe mir
gedacht weil wir gerade ganz viele lotus
kekse im schrank unternimmt sie immer so
provisorisch einfach mal mit man könnte
er brauchen machen wir einen erdbeer
cheesecake ohne backen mit lotus keks
boten ich glaube die kombi wird der
hammer falls sie keine lotus kekse mögt
was ich jetzt glaubt könnte auch ohne
krieg zu nehmen butterkekse oder egal
welche keks auch immer hafer kekse sind
auch richtig gut ich habe die zutaten
hier beim rezept einfach mal
überschaubar gehalten denn das ist ein
schnelles rezept so schnell gehen wenige
zutaten und trotzdem lecker sein für den
keks boden verwende ich 200 gramm
gefüllte lotus kekse 100 gramm butter
für die erdbeer creme 300 gramm
erdbeeren etwas zitronensaft vier
blätter vega tine dann habe ich hier 100
gramm puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt
250 com frischkäse und 400 gramm
schlagsahne was jetzt hier wichtig ist
schlagsahne und frischkäse stelle ich
noch mal kurz kalt dann könnt ihr hier
direkt schon mal die lotus kekse
zerkleinern entweder in einem in einem
beutel mit einem ausbau starb oder
einfach mit so einem kleinen mixa
[Musik]
sehr gut sieht es aus schaut euch das
mal an richtig lecker da gebe ich jetzt
direkt die flüssige butter dazu
[Musik]
dann habe ich ziehe diese schöne
mischung es kommt bei der butterkeks
mischung immer so ein bisschen darauf an
was für kekse ihr nehmt jetzt gibt es
kekse die haben von natur aus schon viel
fällt dann braucht man weniger butter
und man muss einfach schauen dass die
konsistenz passt also hier ich könnte so
ein bisschen keks vertragen aber ich
finde das verhältnis so jetzt ganz gut
darf halt auch nicht zu trocken sein gab
es muss schön zusammenhalten nehmt ihr
euch am besten einen tortenring stellten
auf 20 cm ein
backpapier oder back folie darunter und
dann kommt da jetzt der keks boden rein
und wird schon flach gedrückt mit einem
glas zum beispiel oder mit einer burger
presse die bürger presse kommt bei mir
immer beim backen zum einsatz
[Musik]
und dann packt ihr den text boden
erstmal in den kühlschrank oder ins
gefrierfach und es geht direkt weiter
mit der erdbeer mache jetzt ist die
erdbeer creme dran dafür gebe ich die
erdbeeren in einen mixer ihr könnt sie
aber auch mit einem pürierstab pürieren
ein bisschen zitronensaft dazu
ja sie hat keine citrus press1 sorry
temperieren
[Musik]
und jetzt ist wichtig ich nehme diese
platine und zwar ist platt negative
praktisch die pflanzliche version zur
blatt gelatine also einfach agar agar
agar benutzer in pulverform auch ganz
gerne hier habt ihr es einfach so das
ist einfach reduzieren könnte das heißt
drei blätter platz negative entsprechend
6 platine und auf der rückseite steht
auch immer wie viel masse es bindet das
ist immer wichtig aber es ist schon hier
diese zwei blätter und wichtig ist bei
agatha blattwerk atheismus gekocht
werden im gegensatz zur latin bei statt
ihnen ist nämlich so wenn ihr mit
gelatine arbeitet nehmt ihr die erdbeer
masse kocht sie aufnehmen sie vom
herunter und löst dann die sprecherin
auf die muss vorher gequollen werden im
wasser bei agata und blattwerk athene
ist also ihr müsst mit kochen damit sich
die bindung damit die binde eigenschaft
einfach sich entfalten kann das heißt
das kommt jetzt hier ein ich nehme jetzt
vier blätter
dann kommen die vier blätter blatt
gelatine in den topf das ehrt papier
kommt dazu
dann geht sie direkt auf den herd das
ganze wird verrührt dann dass ich es
aufkochen und ab dann zähle ich zwei
minuten als ich zählen dann wirklich es
übernimmt erhältlich aber wenn es
auftaucht dann zwei minuten mindestens
das sagt auch so ein bisschen dafür dass
die er dieses app irega verdampft er
dann die flüssigkeit das wasser ist weg
und der geschmack wird also einfach
intensiver der man könnte jetzt auch
sagen okay ich kochte das akg einfach im
wasser auf und gibt es dann zu den
pürierte erdbeeren aber wenn ihr gleich
die erdbeeren auf kocht dann habt ihr
einfach schöne nährt bei konzentraten
schmeckt dann leckere weniger wasser mit
geschmack
[Musik]
dann fühle ich dass jetzt gleich um und
lass es etwas abkühlen und werde in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die sahne steif
schlagen diesmal ohne sommerbad ständig
habe jetzt platine beim abkühlen nur
aufpassen
gelatine kühlt nicht so schnell ab und
verliert nicht so schnell platinum ag
kühlen schneller ab und verlieren
schneller auch schon wenn sie laufen sie
das heißt jetzt hier in den kühlschrank
stellen dass es schneller geht denn es
geht gleich ganz schnell und was ich
hier immer machen könnt wenn ihr sicher
gehen wollt dass es auch wirklich
funktioniert
und eure masters iliad macht in der
probe das heißt hier von nehme ich mir
einfach ein esslöffel ihnen ein kleines
schälchen stellt kurz in kühlschrank und
wenn es innerhalb von minuten ungefähr
fest wird dann weiß ich dass die masse
verliert ich bin so eine show die probe
sollte immer machen weil man kann ja nie
wissen es kann ja auch mal sein dass
einfach zutaten schlecht sind oder
irgendwas nicht funktioniert hat und
wenn es nicht fest werden würde würde
ich einfach nochmal weiterkochen
schaut mal so sieht jetzt die probe aus
das heißt sie ist schon fest geworden
und ich kann mit der masse
weiterarbeiten ich werde jetzt hier
einfach in die warme wasser ein löst
sich das noch schön auf
dann kann ich jetzt den quark verrühren
mit
puderzucker
hoppla
mit puderzucker und werden läge strucks
und jetzt müsst ihr wirklich ein
bisschen schnell arbeiten denn die masse
fängt jetzt an zu studieren das heißt im
moment dürfen wir nicht verpassen kurz
den quark rühren
und dann ruhig jetzt die etwa 80 hier
rein
jetzt habe ich die sahne unter
das am besten jetzt mit schneebesen
[Musik]
und dann finde ich die masse bereits in
den tortenring
einem schönen kleid streichen
[Musik]
und dann konnte torte schon zum kühlen
in den kühlschrank das war um später
wird dekoriert
jetzt kann ich den schnellen dzsudzsak
fertig stellen also erstmal auf eine
tortenplatte setzen dann den tortenring
lösen und ich habe jetzt hier schon mal
eine erdbeer soße zubereitet und habe
dafür einfach 200 gramm erdbeeren vom
grünen also das grün entfernt zucker
dazu und püriert und das ganze auf
kochen lassen bis nur noch kleine blume
blazy übrig sind dann wisst ihr nämlich
dass das papier schon einlegt und dann
kurz abkühlen lassen und
dann können wir das jetzt gleich als
erstes auf die tote geben
eigentlich geht's auch ohne aber ich
habe mir gedacht bei dem kiesweg da muss
schon noch mal rein auch nur soße
dann stehe ich immer einmal mit der
palette drüber und jetzt nämlich auch
schön platz
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr immer
gerne die angeschnittenen erdbeeren mit
dem tortenguss zum sprühen besprühen
denn dann trocknen sie nicht und sie
oxidieren nicht werden nicht schlecht
und sind einfach länger haltbar also
generell bei früchten einfach gerne agas
prey dieses tortenguss britt drauf
machen oder zum beispiel mit torten kurs
oder erwärmter marmelade einfach
bestreichen jetzt dürfen die torte
probieren wie gesagt eine schnelle
erdbeertorte etwa käsekuchen und heute
darf einen gast probieren eine freundin
von uns ist das uns war die frau und mit
florence arbeiten wir auch schon lange
zusammen hat bekommen
und zwar arbeitet florence bei wasch
tatsächlich im marketing deswegen
arbeiten wir auch schon lange zusammen
seid glaubt also wir jetzt zwei kennen
uns seit
333 war mit bosch zusammen schon seit
langem stimme schon länger zusammen und
dann kam's woraus somit ins team ja und
es ist immer schön weil wir viele drews
zusammen haben und die menschen ja ich
hoffe dass dieses jahr wieder
stattfindet
ja jetzt würde ich ja auch mal eine
video premiere nicht immer hinter der
kamera diese hübsche frau ist nehmen wir
immer mit vor die kamera
ok ich hab' den kuchen jetzt ein
bisschen draussen stehen gehabt kukksi
ich vergesse manchmal nach der
fotosession die torte zu kühlen deswegen
steht
ich habe die hoffnung dass sie schmeckt
wie ein sanken ja
und du probierst nicht oder ob ihr baut
ihr angebot
knackiger bude
voll cremig
sie ist so richtig gut
dass ich gut was ich gemacht habe das
foto
mit dem boden möchte lecker dieser krank
um das cremige der lotus fruchtige durch
die erdbeeren und ich muss sagen diese
sind etwa berät das haus noch mal
richtig raus aber noch mal so richtig
erdbeergeschmack poor also probiert das
rezept gerne mal aus ihr habt gesehen
die zutaten sind überschaubar schnell
hergestellt und es ist einfach lecker
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr die torte sogar
mit bisschen einfrieren da hat man so
ein bisschen sonne geleistet ja wieso
ein paar fehse und musik
kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen
und man kann sogar die torte recht
einfach vegan zu bereiten ihm dafür
einfach vegane kekse ich weiß gar nichts
ziel los geht es auf die vegan sind
müssten wir mal kurz schauen ich weiß
bloß zum beispiel diesen vegan auf jeden
fall vegane kekse veganer butter und in
der creme dann einfach statt sahne und
frischkäse eben die pflanzliche
alternative mit agar agar binden und
fertigte habt ja auch ganz ganz schnell
eine vegane erdbeertorte zubereitet ja
das rezept gibt es auf 6 - blog de oder
internet schaut gern vorbei man wünsche
euch viel spaß dabei
was heißt eigentlich
lopicic
es könig franz i
[Gelächter]
said
die
frau war
in bad fredeburg
serie 8 wachsen ja ich das falsche video
für mich als würde ich würde es wird
gekühlt wird gekühlt in boscheln source
hat einen karton sah
was heißt backen so
einfach also vorerst offen
es hat ein castor dollar wie der frische
der
fdj wissen glaube ich das gleiche was
ist diese hommage vormarsch der cutoff
roman schwer
angesagten klamotte vom marsch blasen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt so nie soviel überbacken
nachgedacht uns lösen
ist aber auch den fall sehr lecker
lecker französisch kann
nie mehr so viel leider ist recht kurz
mit baustoffen ja ich muss tatsächlich
noch mal ein bisschen üben
akteure dann per ok
montag dienstag mittwoch
[Musik]